hey guys we're back in in this video
we're going to talk about sweeteners yep
sugar sugar substitute yeah so there's a
couple things that you should know let's
start with molasses okay molasses is
basically the waste product from white
sugar they take sugar cane they take all
the vitamins out and they put it into
molasses but this is where all the
nutrients nutrition is you have minerals
vitamins it's still high in sugar but it
has good amounts of iron and other
minerals calcium so I mean if you're
anemic it might be a good thing but I
don't normally recommend this if you
have any blood sugar issues but white
sugar is terrible this will not create
any dental decay so can I use it that's
what I want to know you can use it in
small amounts maybe for children
occasionally how about for gingerbread
cookies
probably not but here's the thing
if you take white sugar and then people
buy brown sugar they think it's
healthier all it is it's a tiny little
drop of this in white sugar so brown
sugar is really almost equivalent to
white sugar
especially sugar like raw sugar cane
it's the same deal so what if I had one
of these other sugars and I added a
little bit of
molasses to it to make it molass to see
if it's just a small amount I think
it'll be okay
but don't do don't go crazy okay so the
next thing I want to talk about is
stevia
Stevia is completely
um
completely
um no glycemic problems with that it's
an herb it's an Indian herb
um it's very sweet but it gives an
aftertaste well some of them give an
aftertaste for sure and and the thing
that I I have to be careful with with
stevia and cooking is that it doesn't
work one for one when you have recipes
they'd say a cup of sugar you're not
going to put a cup of stevia at least
not
we just have to read every package is
different the stevia here
you use a tiny percent
to each measurement so it's it's not one
to one if you use one to one with this
this is uh Kiva Organics Stevia
super super concentrated they do have a
grid on the back tells you how to use it
but you just have to be careful this one
doesn't really have a lot of aftertaste
I kind of like it I've been using it in
some recipes here and there but the
other thing you have to remember is that
sugar is a bulk in recipes so if you're
replacing a cup of sugar with a
tablespoon of this the chemistry is
going to be a little different so I I've
been playing with all of these things a
lot of you guys ask me can I substitute
this for that you just have to read the
sweetener and see what it substitutes if
it's one for one go for it yeah yeah
okay so now we have this one right here
so just like sugar just like sugar this
is chicory root dietary fiber I like
this I like it a lot I don't like it he
doesn't like it gets a little bit of a
bitter taste but they have the brown and
the white so you can test it out see if
you like it I think this one is the
brown
bitter that you're talking
you're talking um I think this works
great
um I have to be really careful with what
I use because I don't my body doesn't
like erythritol and there are certain
sugar alcohols that give me a little GI
a little intestinal situation this is
not the Ruth we're told no I know this
is why I like it so we got erythritol
that's a sugar alcohol I don't have a
sample here right um the thing about
erythritol it's a low glycemic index but
what's that mean it doesn't affect the
blood sugars very much but it can create
some digestive bloating occasionally or
diarrhea now xylitol is another sugar
alcohol I like Xylitol the best because
it tastes almost identical to Sugar
again it can go you can mess up your
digestive system if you have too much
it's very very toxic to dogs if a dog
consumes a hundred grams
um they'll be dead in 30 minutes so you
have to make sure okay we're not going
to talk about that anymore here's the
thing if you get erythritol or Xylitol
make sure you get non-GMO non-GMO
everything always that was really a
downer we're going to move on to
something else let's go on to this one
right here okay uh I haven't tried this
one yet but this is called uh fiber yum
it's the same thing these are these are
the same light of fiber fiber yum
um I'm really happy about this because
when you're making recipes and it's uh
calls for something liquid like a lot of
these paleo and and sugar-free recipes
have
um
what's it called
um inulin no
okay I'm I'm blanking out it's the the
agave it's agave nectar we don't use
agave nectar it's still too high in
sugars but this fiber yum is great I
have another video that you can check
out uh I make my own maple syrup with
this does nothing to the tummy
it has the least amount of digestive
stress uh interaction basically it's an
ISO multiple
oligosaccharide there you go
fiber yum fiber yeah these two are the
same like you just see if they're an ISO
multo Lego saccharide same thing but
it's just like a syrupy type thing
um it's yeah it's great if you have a
recipe that calls for honey if you have
a recipe that calls for maple syrup
agave nectar this is the thing it's it's
great and like I said you know you might
have a reaction to some of these you
just have to test it out some people do
some don't I'm really sensitive and I'm
fine with them now the maple syrup
recipe we're going to show them is that
part of this
yeah I use fiberium in the maple syrup
here's another maple syrup sugar-free
maple syrup so you can get this is uh
malt this is basically a maltitol yeah
some of my family love this it's got a
great consistency of the sugar-free
syrups I've tried the consistency is
great the smell is great The Taste is
actually really good I cannot eat this
at all
um so again you just have to check it
out for yourself the the what happens is
that a lot of these use their fiber that
is um goes in the digestive system and
your microbes interact with it so if you
don't have the enzymes to break it down
or if it's not going through it can
create a lot of questions
no no are you saying something you
dissing my enzymes yeah sort of uh monk
fruit okay I like it another good
sweetener
um again it can create some digestive
issues if you have too much so you want
to play around some people are sensitive
some people aren't but it's another
sweetener a little glycemic index yeah I
like this just to serve for coffee or
tea kind of thing
um it does have a little aftertaste this
different than sugar of course these all
will they're substitutes but this is
I've found this to be really pricey and
I am a consignment shop
economical girl so if it's super pricey
I'm I'm not going to use it but I test
everything so this is okay this is okay
for our table serving so this this is
probably the best one you want to use
right here well in his opinion it's the
best I think this is the best
um and the fiberium
so there you go you guys had a lot of
questions about what can you substitute
what can you use and I'm always
answering saying you just have to check
it out
um and definitely read the ingredients
if you're using a Stevia product
to see how much you need to measure but
you should play with it
um yeah and put your comments below yeah
thanks